I think you're likely to find this next story
either absolutely disgusting or hilarious
depending on whether your instinct is to laugh
or cry in these horrible situations.
There's this guy named Rich Lowry Lit.
Rich Lowry is widely considered to be one
of the smart conservatives by some, OK.
But there's a contingent that says this is
one of the smart conservatives.
He's an alternative to cartoonish right wingers
like the Fox News people and Stephen Miller
and whatever.
A Rich Lowry is the editor of The National
Review.
It's a sort of establishment right wing publication.
And Rich tweeted yesterday, and this is when
I realized satire was dead for the right,
like the right doesn't understand satire.
Rich Lowry tweeted.
Trump rightfully slamming the just the flu
argument at this briefing, referring to Trump
yesterday, saying during his press briefing,
this is not the flu.
This is vicious.
This was Trump's own lie.
Rich Lowry is praising Trump, first slamming
the lie that Trump propagated just a few days
ago and certainly for several weeks.
And it's a lie which is now repeated by millions
of Trump ists who are ignoring all social
distancing guidelines.
Trump is the one who from the beginning was
making this seemingly innocuous comparison.
It's sort of like the flu.
Remember Trump tweeted on March 9th.
So last year, 37000 Americans died from the
flu.
It averages 27 to 70000 per year.
Nothing is shut down life in the economy.
Go on.
We've got five hundred and forty six confirmed
cases of the virus with 22 deaths.
Think about that.
Here is video of Trump saying this could be
called a flu.
Just four days ago, this was not in February.
This was four days ago.
Pandemic by this disease.
This whatever they want to call.
You got a germ.
You can call it a flu.
You can call it a virus.
You know, you can call it many different names.
I'm not sure anybody even knows what it is.
Here's Trump talking about it like the flu.
For weeks.
Wash your mouth so you have to do that.
You know, this is I really think, Doctor,
you want to treat this like a treat, the flu.
Right.
And, you know, it's gonna be it's gonna be
there anyway.
You all know this.
I don't have to play 10 clips of it, but it's
Trump who kept inserting into the narrative.
Flu.
And here is Trump yesterday saying, hey, guys,
this is not the flu.
This is vicious.
People with great actually common sense.
They said, what are we write at?
A lot of people have said a lot of people
have thought about it, write it out, don't
do anything.
Just write it up and think of it as the flu.
But it's not the flu.
It's vicious.
And then incomes.
Rich Lowry.
And again, says Trump, rightfully slamming
the just the flu argument at this briefing.
This is like praising someone for putting
out a fire that they deliberately started.
This is like punching someone in the face
and saying, I didn't punch me twice.
You know, I that you've got to give me some
credit for not having punched you a second
time.
This guy is a supposed smart conservative.
Have fun with that one.
So I think what we have to realize here is
when we point this stuff out, here's the important
message.
A lot of people, when they first hear it's
like the flu or they hear Fox News say the
airports are empty.
This is a great time to be flying or they
hear Devin Nunes, this Republican congressman
from California, say this is a great time
to go to restaurants because the restaurants
are wide open.
You'll very easily be able to find a seat.
When we when we hear all that stuff and then
it gets worse and the guidelines change.
There are a lot of people who do a sort of
pick your.
It's like a choose your own adventure, pick
whichever position you like.
Trump has now said 20, 30 times.
It's sort of like the flu in different ways.
It's a flu.
We don't shut down for the flu, whatever,
yesterday.
He says this is not the flu.
This is vicious.
Millions of Americans are continuing to sort
of rely upon the 20 or 30 times, Trump said.
It is like the flu in some some way, shape
or form to continue, not social distancing,
to continue going out there, congregating
in large groups.
I know that, you know, here in Massachusetts,
we are now halfway through week three of doing
this.
People are taking it seriously.
Almost everything's closed.
Nobody's going to school.
The streets are widely empty.
People at grocery stores are being very, very
careful.
There are still states at this point that
are barely doing anything.
And I know that there are people in red states
who listen to the show, who write to me and
say, David, you know, even though our state
hasn't done anything within my city, we have
done stuff.
The mayor.
That's great.
OK.
That that's fantasy.
But there are millions and millions of people,
it's estimated to be 25 percent of the total
population or more.
Right.
We're talking about eighty million people.
We have three hundred forty million people
in this country.
Twenty five percent would be about eighty
five million people who are still not doing
any kind of social distancing.
And this is the sort of reason why.
So we've got to be much more vigilant about
it.
We're fighting.
You know, Trump wants to consider himself
a wartime president when it comes to fighting
the virus.
I don't know whether that's that's the right
language to be using.
But a real battle that is being fought is
the battle against disinformation, which is
just spreading virally from the right.
And we're going to continue following it and
fighting it as best we can